a Vixens i'm leanna Galera and welcome
to our special preview episode for
chapter 18 when a stranger called
and I've got a very special guest right
now I've been hiding behind those
pom-poms how are you thank you so much
for coming on to Sweetwater secrets for
having me so we do are you so much and
of course I am paying homage to you I
mean beautifully done why thank you
why thank you we have so much to discuss
because this week's episode is massive
lots of lots of things happen so many
things happen but we're gonna rewind to
ever-so-slightly and look to last week's
episode because you guys have been
sending in so many fan comments all
about your hisses and kisses and
Madeline and I are going to read some
for you right now so I will take the
first one and these ones are for you
Madea Oh whoo oh yes mine are so
official I know oh they're very official
so our first comment is going to be from
juju which I love that handle name right
now and she says I'm starting to become
more excited about Sweetwater secrets
than Riverdale itself oh that's really
nice my hisses tawny topes girl year one
salty cracker my kisses are to veronica
and how she's always there for Archie
and proving that they are more than just
a physical couple I think their
relationship is getting more in depth by
the episode and another big kiss to
Alice Cooper who continuously sits on
her laptop with a glass of wine you go
Alice Cooper amen would it be Alice
Cooper do you think you do I think I do
Mads you have a comment for us mmm Tessa
Lowe's says hisses I want more Cheryl
she is Savage and I need her and I don't
know about phony how dare she dissed
Betty's ponytail
Betty's ponytail is iconic and beyond
reproach well just friendly reminder
guys we are not the characters that we
play on the show my best friend is tawny
topaz okay Vanessa Morgan and she's we
ending a lot of hate so let's all be
nice to the actresses please and then
your kisses Tessa
our I love Kevin so much and
just come back and I liked it when the
Bulldogs had our cheese back and bar she
was amazing this episode with a little
question mark emoji because iPhone X I
just fixed it like today like breaking
news the iPhone X has fixed the question
work as of I just checked our next
comment is from Ellie N and she says big
hits to Jughead ignoring Betty's call to
talk to Tony and saying I'll call her
back then continue to send ready a lame
sorry talk tomorrow text several hours
later at a time when she would have been
able to talk anyways get your act
together dude amen
it's seriously though girls everywhere
we know what that's like call me back
text her back
you don't where's cousin that we know
what that's like cuz we don't know what
that's like because our boyfriends are
great my boyfriend's back sometimes
[Laughter]
Matty beba says I would like to see
Cheryl and Toni together that would be
really interesting but I'm scared that
she might ruin bug-head relationship we
will have to see dun dun dun
that's the emoji she does so the reason
that she was saying that she wanted Toni
and Cheryl to be together is because on
last week's preview show I actually said
I'm kind of already shipping you guys
and I don't even know if it's gonna
happen I have no idea I have no idea
where all of this came from with all of
a sudden I feel like in the last month
it's been like Tony Tony Tony and I'm
like I don't know where you guys got
this idea from like Tony and Cheryl are
Tony you like Tony
it's your Tony or Terrell isn't it it's
like what are my other options what are
the options send us your comments right
now but really though to me me me I
don't know how I feel but I'll be honest
neither of the ship names they don't
have it's pretty neat-looking pretty me
could happy a possibility anything's
possible I'll never know you know that I
gotta keep friends from you girl oh um
let's look ahead to this week's episode
we actually have the promo and Matt's
and I are gonna provide you with amazing
commentary while we watch it yeah look
the face under the hood what I recognize
it
the black couldcould you yes wanna stand
with you guys
are you joining the serpent
[Music]
don't hurt her why is the picture of me
my boyfriend up right now can we just
talk about like how sweet you guys are
so sweet
I love Cheryl's got the worst luck in
relationships but you seem to be doing
just fine I'll be honest girl this is
this is the new thing for me like I
don't usually have luck in relationships
but I genuinely do have the best
boyfriend the planet
shut up well continuing on that thread
you know there Cheryl was giving quite a
flirty wave in that promo
who's she waving to girl watch the
episode won't ya I guess so I guess so
but what can you tease about this we not
a lot okay cuz a lot goes down and we're
gonna be discussing all of it on our
aftershow and Mads will be joining us
for then as well but so what are you
allowed to eat and send love to say Nick
st. Claire comes into town which is
Veronica's ex-boyfriend yeah he causes
some trouble there's black hood stuff in
it
we know that Betty was on the phone with
the black eye right crack and obviously
she seems very distraught and how
terrified should we be of this nemesis
berry yeah he's deadly well we know he's
killed before could there be more deaths
coming in Riverdale like I said anything
is possible in Riverdale I got a text
from Roberto who's our showrunner and
creator before we started this season in
our group text and it was a photo of all
of us like I think it was the photo from
the wedding that one of us posted yeah
and it was like the whole entire cast
with exes through some of the faces and
he was like who's next
and I was like oh my god it's like so
much anxiety every time you got a script
you're like dying who's gonna die they
would surely give you a heads up though
they would give you a courtesy call you
never know like I said anything's
possible in Riverdale we're gonna do
some speed run questions okay do you
think that Clifford blossom is actually
dead what yeah yeah really what are you
talking about well anything's possible
in Riverdale right okay fair fair fair I
personally do I did see his body hanging
from the rafters so I personally think
he is but you never know
blossoms are sneaky ones you could
definitely have had some kind of
contraption on his body to save his neck
what do you think about Cheryl's dynamic
with Penelope this season as of what
we've seen so far I find it very
interesting I'm very happy that she's
kind of taking the reins back it gets a
lot more complex and a lot more
interesting and she'll becomes
a lot more human as the season goes on
which I love and I'm so happy about I've
got to tell you you and Lily have been
crushing your Betty and Cheryl scenes
lately so good the super fun Girl Talk
scene oh my god was so perfect Davidge
what has it been like for you guys to
share so many scenes in butt heads it's
been fun I mean people ask me all the
time like how could I be so mean to my
best friends but I'm like those are the
people you want to do this with like if
I was to be like an awful human being
like Cheryl to these two people I didn't
know I would be like mortified Oh
completely because I'd be like oh my god
I'm so sorry I've ever seen but then I
couldn't walk away and be like she knows
it's so much fun and it was a really fun
- to have the dynamic kind of change
between Betty and Cheryl in that
particular scene because Betty finally
for once was like kind of putting her
black big-girl boots on you're a
stone-cold [ __ ] Betty Cooper
I need more vixens when are we gonna get
to see more from them I'm gonna tell you
right now I don't think it's Olympic I
don't think that I actually have done
very many vixen scene since this picture
here I haven't done much I don't believe
we are gonna be getting more from the
Pussycats
very very soon I need to know could
share I'll be joining them again
I mean look episode 2 - so much fun so
great I would always love to do more
musical performances on Riverdale what
are you excited about about this season
so much has been going on um in the
future Cheryl's future there's a lot of
really fun stuff happening
still got an unexpected love interest
coming my way at some point when there's
a little sprinkling of its before 12 and
then there's like I think most of its
going to have to call me tiny little
little raindrops little chocolates yeah
Oh Dean wants to know if you could be
any other character in Riverdale who
would you be mm-hmm
so the question Dean Jughead
really or FP like a serpent okay you
know the opposite yeah you know they
ride motorcycles and I want to ride a
motorcycle
I would like to ride a motorcycle on the
show not in real life
Andy so like a high person but like the
images would be solid the images are
really solid from episode 6 though you
guys I can't wait for you guys to see oh
love that when you get to wear things
like this are you just like yes honestly
I feel like there's never a moment when
I'm not like yes I'm gonna look at my
wardrobe I just got such a fun order a
fan had actually commented a couple
shows ago forgive me I don't have your
comment directly in front of me right
now but she had said Cheryl was wearing
her spider brooch but she had given that
to Jughead I get that question all the
time they want to know how I got it back
and it's kind of like it's not in the
script obviously it's a kind of reading
between the lines back to her after she
tried to take her own life
and like when they were all in that
moment together it's like kind of
insinuated that he gave back to her it's
mine I got it back yeah you know what
pairs really well with spiders
what thanks MA I didn't get it for a
second but I get it now sure Rhodey yeah
I think it's cute I'm here I'm here look
I I also would ship it yeah as madelung
yes I don't know what actually like you
know that's gonna go down I don't know
it's gonna go down but like I think I'm
down for whatever okay another question
for you does Jason blossom ever speak mm
right now he is not speak that sucks
yeah he actually fun fact does the actor
in real life have a nice voice he sure
doesn't speak oh there's actually really
fun fact in the first episode you know
when I asked Jason if he's scared yeah
originally that was Jason's line and he
was said are you scared Cheryl and like
what's doing all and have it be you
saying it and now it's like this almost
like funny thing that he's members of
the line things people didn't know about
Riverdale um but we actually are out of
time right now but I could babble with
you about Riverdale all go but thank you
all so much for tuning into our preview
episode of Sweetwater secrets make sure
you tune in after you watch chapter 18
when a stranger calls for all of our
hisses and kisses on the episode Mads is
gonna be sharing hers as well and she'll
also be weighing in on the episodes most
shocking moment you do not want to miss
it be sure to LIKE this video subscribe
to each his YouTube page all that good
stuff and oh click the link in my
description below to ring the bell so
you never miss an episode of Sweetwater
secrets I did I think I hit no that was
a really impressive wait thank you
alright guys thanks again so much I'm
Liana Giller
patch your daugh really room babes
[Music]
you